in a Natural History Museum in Rostock
Germany is the toughest stork that has
ever lived in 1822 in Germany a hunter
shot a stork but when he went to pick it
up he noticed that it had some
additional baggage with it sticking
through its neck was a huge spear but
what turned out to be a terrible day for
this stork was really good day for
Natural History because he had found
what they went on to call the FiOS door
or the arrow store where birds went for
the winter was for a long time a total
mystery and there were a lot of theories
thrown out there Aristotle believed that
basically one bird species would just
transform into a different one we was
actually describing were migratory
patterns one bird would leave for the
winter and another bird would come to
Greece for the winter and he would say
oh that bird just turned into the other
bird it's like a you know caterpillar
turning into a butterfly
another theory was that they hibernated
the birds would bury themselves in the
mud
at the edges of lakes and it even went
so far as to say that sometimes
fishermen would catch them and dredge
them up but they made bad eating so you
know it wasn't worth it in the 1600s a
guy named Charles Morton he had a new
proposal he thought they went to the
moon well this sounds insane to us now
he made a pretty coherent argument we
didn't know about the whole atmosphere
on earth and not on the moon thing the
1600s were also a time when people
believed the basically alien life
existed on our moon on other planets and
it wasn't that much of a stretch to
believe that certain earth creatures
particularly birds because they could
fly might actually make a visit there
it's not as if no one thought of the
idea of migration as we think of it now
there were a couple of guys in
particular who were like yeah like I
think birds probably just fly to like
you know faraway places like Asia or
Africa and everyone was like
week the stork was one of these species
that seemed to just vanish so when this
German hunter shot this store with a
huge arrow through its neck it pointed
to a less extraterrestrial but no less
astonishing conclusion that arrow that
was sticking through its neck was an
African spear that stork had flown 3,000
kilometers down to Africa for the winter
been a road through the neck and flown
3,000 kilometers back to Germany they
took this species they taxidermy dead
arrow still in there exactly as it was
and it's been in the Natural History
Museum of Rostock since the 1800s
amazingly this is not the only arrow
stork that has been found since then 25
different cases of thyristor have been
recorded and subscribe here and watch
more videos here to all you aro
Historics keep up your game it really is
like some next-level stork action I hope
there are Arrow's storks right now that
got away